yeah hello welcome to this video playing
Gregorio powering sorry I have played
him once that's a pretty young Russian
GM if I'm not mistaken I won that game
that's good that earlier game with spin
a while I guess not I got played him
yesterday so g3 line can't make sure not
to allow night a for I did that in a
recent game that wasn't any good so he's
trying for some f4 business I guess
yeah okay and Cal Kessler first and see
now what I do
he's probably preparing it for him hmm
and whatever I can just go back and go
ahead five myself let's try that okay
seems he's ready for this mmm okay let's
take and see what happens here
in my t complain 95 hmm okay
don't like that position so much I can't
have no big choice that I have to take
oh that one okay hmm no tactics
available from here Daiichi foreign
Queen age 4 hmm it doesn't seem to work
you know the problem is if I go back his
kids going g5 and they should be 5 Queen
age 5 and that is kind of awful Wow okay
let me trouble
hmm Wow okay Bishop d7 G 598 check and
then Queen h5 wow that's very bad
amazing how bad this position is didn't
if like I did so much wrong but it seems
to be okay I mean that is not going to
work but check I couldn't find a way to
play normally so maybe I can at least
irritate him a little bit him don't know
how though I was thinking G fire but
that's just ridiculous he can go a night
she to or something it's completely
wrong wow what a bad bad way to play
nice of 95 only slight OBC plays instant
moves thinking he will win with
everything which is probably true but
this is always a slight chance if the
opponent thinks that he would win with
every move and I'm not sure that it is
that easy
of course is completely winning I am NOT
arguing about that
especially if I play crap like that why
do I run into that I didn't even
calculate a single move him didn't see
neither for coming at all
he I should have taken this yeah I mean
he's got a big attack anyway okay
there's not much to do no it was not
really terrible I was just completely
lost day after g-form
amazingly enough I'm just closing here
after g4 I didn't see that coming but it
is so bad the normal move Bishop d7
loses two to Jesus to g5
I have no moves him know I can I can
layups some similarly hopeless sacrifice
but this is losing losing the house I
was thinking Queen h5 but in fact he can
actually check already Queen h5 is also
winning I guess 95 week it's lost
yeah I'm just losing here I can I do I
try to I try to stir up some trouble but
I was playing that part of the game
badly he was actually allowing some
stuff stuff Queen e5 couldn't be true
and I am it's not that great yeah that
is just ridiculous running into Knight
f4 t9h five wins yeah that was just
amazing how bad that was probably f5 is
just a rubbish idea I should just play
something normal here stockfish wants to
play Knight f6 back that's cool it's not
a fan of 98 but it gives me a slight
advantage I don't know why I have to
have four White's why it seems to be
okay no I mean that's it's a normal
position f5 it seems that at least I
have to play differently here
it doesn't look right doesn't look right
okay it's amazing how bad this is
yeah I mean I can also not take this
this is all so bad Wow okay now I have
to refresh this opening definitely
that's not a good way to defend okay
thanks for watching